Say your music app plays you a song you love, by a band you have never heard of.
Two descriptions get compared in a data center and the verdict comes back: same taste.
But weigh what that comparison has to do.
A song is not one number.
It is loud, fast, sad, bright, many qualities at once, and your taste is that same tangle.
No single ruler works here, because the ruler that measures loud says nothing about sad.
And waiting for two tangles to agree on every quality at once is a lottery you would never win,
so the comparison needs a principled way to collapse many measurements into one.
So try it first.
How would you boil the match between two many-featured things down to a single number?
Harder than it sounds.
One answer to it runs half of modern machine learning.
You just tried to score that match by hand, and it fought back.
Add everything up and loudness wins, not agreement.
Count exact matches and nothing ever matches.
Here is the move that lands it.
A taste is an arrow: each direction is one quality,
and the length is how hard the song leans that way.
The recipe is almost embarrassingly small.
Multiply the two arrows entry by entry, then add.
If your taste is two and one, and a song is one and three,
that is two times one plus one times three: five.
One number, the whole tangle collapsed.
Now meet the instrument.
One probe arrow, the thing doing the asking.
Four candidates, holding still, and under each candidate a bar showing its current score.
Before anything moves, call your shot,
and make it one the sweep can prove wrong: as the probe turns, does any score go negative?
Now the sweep, and everything on screen is frozen except the probe.
As the probe turns toward a candidate, that bar climbs.
As it turns away, the bar dies.
The candidates never moved, so direction is the only thing the score can be reading.
So a big score means two songs are the same, right?
Now watch what length does.
One candidate stretches longer, direction pinned, and its bar climbs anyway,
on length alone, even though its direction never got closer.
The score reads agreement of direction, not sameness,
and a long arrow can fake a high number.
Look at what your hands just learned.
Point the probe along a candidate and the sum climbs.
Point it across and the sum dies to zero.
Point it against and the sum goes negative.
One multiply and add, and it behaves like a meter with agree,
ignore, and oppose on the dial.
So say it plainly: the dot product is a similarity meter.
Two lists of numbers go in.
One honest reading of alignment comes out.
And the reading tracks direction, because direction is all the sweep ever changed.
Time to close the loop.
Rebuild the meter from memory: two arrows go in,
and which two operations turn them into a single score?
Hold your answer while the opening scene comes back.
Your app played you a stranger's song and called it your taste.
You know what that took now.
Your taste is the probe.
The catalog is a shelf of candidates, thousands of arrows long.
And the machine in the data center is the thing you just built,
running multiply-and-add a few million times and handing you the top bar.
That was the whole mystery: your meter, at scale.
Now the honest look, and guess before you watch.
You saw length raise the score.
But by how much?
Double c1's length exactly, same direction,
just twice as long: does the score double exactly, or just drift up?
It doubles, exactly.
Four point two becomes eight point four, to the last digit.
Double one input, double the output: the meter is linear in each arrow you feed it.
That clean scaling is the crack.
A loud song wins on sheer loudness, whether or not the taste underneath agrees,
because size passes straight through the arithmetic.
Take it with you.
A song and a taste, folded into arrows,
collapsed by multiply-and-add into one score: a meter with a crack in it.
One more aisle, to make sure it lands: score yourself against a job posting.
Same multiply-and-add, one number for the fit.
Now invent your own pair.
Anything you can describe as two matching lists, the meter can score.
For the walk home: what is the cheapest fix that keeps the direction and forgets the size?
Still up?
The menu below has three ways to keep going.